in 91 if somebody went to you and said
in 2016
you're gonna be on The Tonight Show with
the roots playing Sam man with kids
instruments what would you have said or
done to that person yeah yeah you're
you're on drugs you're high whatever but
I tell you there's there's so many fun
adventures that happen in Metallica yeah
things just come at us and we we either
embrace them or or kind of put the
blinders on no that's not for us yeah
what was that that was a lot of it
looked like a lot of fun
it it it certainly was yeah just being
in that tight little room I mean we may
be rehearsed it a couple times and went
over it and it's like okay that's enough
stop don't make it too good you know I
remember Kirk was in the in the tuning
room he's like practicing this little
thing on whatever he was playing the
recorder or something as I said dude why
are you trying to learn this thing man
you know the roots will handle it let's
just have fun with it so it was really
was it what do you do for fun when
you're you know I know you we talked
about don't sound fun no no no but what
do you do like what do you what do you
do now to sort of you know enjoy
yourself when you're along the road like
what are you doing now is a grown 53
year old is that like do you experience
different things in cities that maybe
you tore up years ago
do you try fine you tried fine to go and
rebuild patch holes in walls and yeah
clean up barf yeah well yeah the second
half of your life is like you're making
up for the first half right yeah I I
find things to do whether you know if
the family's out that's a whole nother
thing you know it's it's museums it's
torn erasers doing kind of touristy
stuff which is a lot of fun and you know
introducing the kids of the culture you
know a lot of these places we've been to
a lot and trying to discover what's new
in that town or whatever you know most
of the time it's depending on where if
there's a real
huge crazy fan base outside of the hotel
yeah there's a lot of fun trying to
sneak out yeah that's fun and train 2
goes to a quiet restaurant somewhere or
watch the game somewhere you know I hang
out with the inner crew kind of people I
got you know - this thing a PT out here
and we just go out and have a good meal
or you know watch games that we just
laughs you know we crack each other up
there's some cool combo there you know
stay connected with home a lot easier
these days you know with what do you
snap chatting with your kids
yeah face with the kids sure and the
wife but get out and walk yeah I like
doing that just get out and walk go get
lost
you know just discover things that way
yeah when when it comes to a record like
this whoo because you were talking about
that really ship between you and Lars
when something is done who's the one
that says it's done yeah who gets to say
when something is done because it's a
great question because it can it can go
on forever it can go on forever
we are perfectionist and no stone
unturned they you know hey we haven't
tried this already we had didn't it
you know there's a you know there's a
constant argument between Lara and I
about something always you know we're
brothers
song length is one of those things you
know is it done if it's eight minutes
you know let's try and get it tighter
yes I would say that obviously the
vocals solos are kind of the last things
than the mix you know you just kind of
feel it and in will will respect each
other's stuff when it comes to listening
and we listen to the one for you one for
him one for you one for him is that the
way that's not silly but you know we'll
sit in the car yeah he listening to
music in the car is like the best thing
that's for us so you do that and you
know you're not super focused on up
you're just hearing I was there no
that part could be better yeah you know
and whenever both of us are satisfied
it's done